thank you for attending my talk I'm
going to talk about the copy number
transformation problem i will first
present the definition of this problem
and its relevance to this workshop and
afterwards we discuss the algorithm we
obtain to solve it efficiently and this
is a joint work with juan chamula no
one's a year from tel aviv university so
before presenting the definition of the
problem we need the following
definitions of copy number CS so a copy
number profile is a vector where they
are the entry and the ice position VI is
the number of copies of gene I and we
assumed that VI is a non-negative
integer so for example here we have two
copies of the second gene in this copy
number for file an application is a
triple L h1 the third argument is always
one and its range includes every integer
between l and age including ln age now
given a copy number profile it
increments by one the valuated entry
that belongs to its range unless this
value is zero in which case it remains
zero so for example here when Clemente
by one the values at the third and the
fifth entries and the value in the
fourth century with each 0 remain CEO
and a deletion is defined similarly now
we decrement by one the value at each
entry that belongs to the range unless
it is 0
now a genome can evolve over time using
a serious of their modifications called
the arrangement and combinatorial
algorithmic methods to detect the
serious have been the subject of
extensive study in the last two decades
here i just want to mention that the
majority of the models they'll assume
that each gene as a single copy or
result in an np-hard problem so this
models are limited in their ability to
handle complex genomes such as console
and it is also appropriate to consider
distances between copy number profiles
now before i define such a distance i
also want to mention that there are well
known methods to detect copy number
profiles and that our algorithm is
aspects of questions related to these
distances gained little scientific
attention to date and here we will use
an own definition that is the based on
segmental a amplifications and deletions
which will we'll see on the next slide
so to present the problem formally let s
and t be to copy number profiles now a
copy number transformation from s to t
is a vector C of implications and
deletions for some non negative integer
m such that when we apply these
amplifications and deletions one after
another 30 c 1 and c 2 and so on
starting at the copy number profile s we
will opportunity here you can see an
example of a such a transformation from
s to t where red and green blocks
indicate delicious & amplifications
respectively so we get from s to T
now as expected the distance from s to T
is the smaller side of the copy number
transformation from s to T and the copy
number transformation problem asked us
to the a compute this distance and one
can also want to obtain the a
transformation that realizes this
distance we show the copy number
transformation problem can resolve in
linear time and constant space now to
this end we use three steps first we
prove several for keep opposition's
about the nature of the problem at hand
and using this for positions to obtain
the dynamic programming based algorithm
the service time and space complexities
where capital n is the maximum copy
number in the input and afterwards by
will by using a piecewise linear
function to improve this algorithm and
obtain our main result a linear time
constant space algorithm so I will say a
few words about a each step before them
there is a certain type assessing step
that I skip due to lack of time so let's
look at the pole position so the first
proposition state that it is sufficient
to look at copy number transformations
where all of the deletions plac'd all of
the amplification now when you think
about the opposite proposition stating
that it is sufficient to examine copy
number transformation where all of the
amplifications take place before all of
the deletions then this position is not
to all and you can see this by looking
at this example which we've already seen
in a previous slide and you can see that
here we have a copy number
transformation of sizes today but if you
demand that all of the amplification
will take place before of the deletions
then it is no longing to you cannot find
a copy number transformation of society
and the intuition behind this is that we
want to get to zero values as soon as
possible because it
doesn't matter if we have an
amplification or deletion they stay 0 so
this is why we want to have deletions as
soon as possible now the second
proposition states that it is sufficient
to examine copy number transformations
they do not contain both the deletion
that affects si but not as I plus 1 and
a deletion that affects as I plus 1 but
not SI and the same store for
amplifications now if you look at a copy
number transformation where all of the
deletions take place before all of the
amplifications then it is actually very
easy to see that this proposition is
true because in this case you can just
repeat replace such to a delicious by
one and obtained a shorter copy number
transformation if we are looking at the
indexed I such that TI is greater than 0
then and we know how many deletions
affect SI when you want to reach TI then
we can compute exactly how many
amplifications should affect it however
if a TI is 0 then this is no longer to
go okay we can know how many deletions
effect SI but we cannot compute compute
exactly how many amplification should
affect it but in this case we have a
proposition that actually states that we
do not have to stop information about
how many deletions and amplification the
fact is I if TI is 0 and here i do not
give the precise statement of this
proposition that just disciplic ation
and finally off of proposition states
that the maximum number of delicious and
amplification that can affect each as I
can be bounded by n where we call that a
capital n is the maximum copy number in
the input now by using lists for
positions we can obtain a recursive
formula that naturally leads to the
development of dynamic programming based
algorithm
and the idea is that we use a table em
that has an entry for every in text I
between one and n and for every day
between zero and capital N and in this
certain entering want to store the size
of an optimal a transformation form a
perfect of s to apply fixed of T taking
the first I entities and such that
exactly the delicious effect st I now I
won't discuss the coffee farmer formula
and the notation in details I just want
to mention that when we compute a such
an entry we just look at the previous
index well T I was not zero ok and we
look at the best d prime that we can
choose the best number of deletions that
correspond to this entry and to this
already computed value we add values
that correspond to the number of new
deletions that we need the number of new
amplifications that we need and another
value that is related to the zero
entries in T that appealed immediately
before the a TI the entry devaluated
entry i now you can see that we have
here this number of entries and each of
them can be computed in this time thank
you because we have this minimization
hill so we obtain this run next time ok
but we want to obtain an arboretum a
linear time algorithm that has a
constant space so to this end we use
piecewise linear functions and the main
idea that we show that the table m can
be described by ona piecewise linear
functions where each of them encapsulate
all of capital n entries and we also saw
that each test function is well-behaved
this means that each dust has drill in
our segments ok so now instead of
looking of all of capital n entries when
we compute one end to end
Bell we can only look on one well
behaved function and therefore the time
to compute it is now constant okay and
moreover we show the ten of the size of
the table shrinks okay we just have this
number o of n functions to compute and
therefore because we have this number of
a new entries of functions and each of
them can be computed in constant time we
obtain a linear time algorithm and it
can also be shown that it is a constant
space I'll go with Emma so this is
almond result thank you for your
attention hi I'm very nice to have a
great question and so suppose I'm given
to copy number products and I cannot
transform one into the other what is the
artists of finding like a standard
problem so public profile that is an
ancestor of both and then basically from
that ancestor you want to get the first
copy profound the other one such that
the number of events the total number of
events is this is a good question and we
are currently working on it okay look in
there because thanks were also
underscores from the Schwartz at all we
did that actually um to follow up on
that question we use this dynamic
programming implementation it's great to
see that we continued and I think
particular because the complexity is
very high when you want to do the
ancestral reconstruction to get the
minimum tree that has the shortest
overall trillion especially we have no
for the same reason why traditional
phylogenetic with in dells is
complicated because in your we had a
finite state machine representation than
your state space explodes and so I need
to prune when you walk up the trees such
as I rhythm would be very very useful to
do a very to do an official and such a
reconstruction which we have to use
heuristics for because of this
complexity issues so we have a solution
but maybe we can find a better one with
this so maybe I related a more detail so
what I said that day we are currently
working on it and I'll go in with an
efficient
time complexity and we have several
direction so if you want to talk about
it later have you certainly a copy
neutral alterations like in versions of
this is another direction that we might
look at currently we are walking and but
with the suggestion question is what
when you select a region for changing
the copy number you assume that all
intervals are equally stream like that
there is no guarantee but could you
comment on what would happen if you
didn't have that assumption could you
still like I think you can still do it
in time that's proportional to big and
he still is the world so I'm not sure
that in this case we can sting describe
the table using piecewise linear
functions so it is possible that the
time complexity would it be lineal
anymore we showed the third argument in
each operation was smart 1 or minus 1
right well give make different
amplifications of like three times the
Caucasus increments so it just three
operations that we already considered
but if you want to give them different
wait for example for three operation to
give the word to then it's a bit
different
ok so this thank the speaker